SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: All right,
so let's get started.
So today, very happy
to have you here.
We are going to talk
about continuing
our discussion on the
two-dimensional and
three-dimensional, waves.
So as I mentioned before, there
are two interesting situation
which we can actually
increase the dimensional.
So for example, I can have
all the objects oscillating
in just one direction,
but I changed the way
that I placed all those
objects in the space.
For example, I
can have particles
which are arranged in two
or three-dimensional arrays.
And we were talking about how to
understand this kind of system.
And all those objects
are oscillating
in just one direction--
for example,
up and down in one direction.
That's actually one measure
we can increase the dimension.
There's another
interesting example
which we will talk
about today is
to change the direction
of the oscillation,
even rotate the natural
electromagnetic waves,
for example.
And how can we
achieve that and how
do we understand this phenomena,
that's actually going to be
covered by the lecture today.
So before we move
forward, we will
have a short review
on what we have
learned from the last lecture.
And this is actually
what we discussed.
If I have two materials,
the left-hand side
and the right-hand side are two
different kinds of materials,
or very thin membranes.
And if I have an
incident wave coming
into the boundary of these
two materials, which is just
x equal to 0, as we
discussed last time,
basically the boundary
condition require
that in order to make sure that
the membrane doesn't break,
that means the k
vector, the projection
in the y direction of the k
vectors has to be the same.
That means the projection of the
wave in the y direction, which
is along this line,
the wavelength of all
the incidents refracted
and transmitted wave,
the wavelengths should
be all the same.
Otherwise, I can change y
and make the membrane break,
or break the boundary condition.
So that's actually
the first thing
which we learned from the
math we were doing last time.
And also, the k value
are not arbitrary, right?
So we were already assuming that
all three waves, all the three
plane waves are oscillating
at the same frequency.
If they are oscillating
at different frequencies,
it doesn't work because
I can change time, then
make the membranes break.
So therefore, all
the three plane waves
will be oscillating at the
same frequency-- omega.
And according to this
formula, so we have defined
and which is actually
the refraction index,
which is equal to some
constant c divided
by the speed of the
propagation, the phase velocity
of the left-hand side material.
And we also can define n
prime, which is actually
equal to c, the same constant,
divided by v prime, which
is the speed of propagation of
the right-hand side material.
And according to the
dispersion relation,
we can calculate what will
be the length of the k
if omega is given.
The omega for the left-hand
side and right-hand,
refracted, transmitted,
and incident waves
should be the same.
Therefore, I can
immediately write down
what would be the
length of the k vector.
And that means the
length of the k vector
would be equal to n
times omega over c.
So c over n is actually
just v. So basically it's
just the non-dispersive
median dispersion relation.
And also you can go
ahead and write down
what would be the
length of the k prime.
And that is actually determined
by n prime omega over c.
So based on these two
interesting formations,
what we can conclude is that
that means k prime and kr
cannot be arbitrary.
They have to be aligned to
form a specific pattern.
The pattern is
that the projection
in the right direction
should be the same.
And also at the same time,
the length of the k vector
is determined by the
refraction index.
So once we fix all that
and put them all together,
we can conclude that based
on the projection in the y
direction, we will
conclude that theta
will be equal to theta r, where
theta is actually that incident
angle and theta r is the
refraction angle, which
is describing the direction
of the refractive wave.
And also the second very
interesting information
we learned is that based
on the boundary condition,
we can conclude n sine theta
will be equal to n prime sine
theta prime.
So that's actually Snell's
law, which some of you
actually learned from
the high school days
or from the earlier
lectures in physics.
And these two
interesting results
form the basis of
geometrical optics or laws.
That's two of the
most important laws we
learn from geometrical optics.
So that actually gives
you some examples
and gives you some
more feeling about what
we are talking about.
So what we are talking about
is that if I have an incident
wave coming into this boundary,
and that incident angle is
theta 1, what I would expect
based on what we have just
derived is that theta
r, the refracted wave
direction, the
refractive wave angle,
the refraction angle would be
equal to the incident angle,
according to what we
have just derived.
I was just rotating
this by 90 degrees.
And also we can calculate
what will be theta 2 according
to Snell's law--
n1 sine theta 1 equal
to n2 sine theta 2.
And if I continue and
propagate the incident wave,
here I assume that n2 is larger.
If you have a larger
refraction index,
that means the speed of
propagation is smaller.
Larger n value give you a
smaller speed of propagation.
Therefore, you can see that the
wavefront, which is actually
the position of
the peak, actually
got delayed compared to
the original projection.
And you can see that the
red line is actually really
what you would see
in the second median.
And then we can also
continue to propagate
and you will see
that, interesting,
that means the plane wave
would change direction because
of the matching
boundary condition,
the membranes doesn't break.
You can see that
the peak position
match from the median number
1 and median number 2.
The peak position, which is the
position of the line, match.
And also, due to the slower
speed of propagation,
the plane wave actually
change direction.
So that's actually
how we can understand
the mathematical result
which we derived last time
by this interesting example.
So that's considered
a situation which
is maybe a little bit
interesting to you.
So what will happen
if I now shoot light
from inside some material which
delay the light slightly--
for example, n1 is equal to 1.5.
I shoot something
through the material,
and then the second material I
have has higher speed of light,
which is actually having
the speed of light
equal to light in a vacuum case.
So in this example, I
have n1 equal to n2.
Since n1 sine theta 1 is
equal to n2 sine theta 2,
so now I can calculate what
will be the resulting theta
2 according to this equation.
So the resulting theta 2
will be sine theta 2 will
be equal to n1 over
n2 sine theta 1.
In this case, n1 is
greater than n2, therefore,
this term is greater than 1.
In this case, actually,
this ratio is equal to 1.5.
So this is actually
pretty interesting.
That means this factor is
actually greater than 1.
I have sine theta 1, which
is multiplied in this vector.
So that means if I increase
theta 1, if I increase
theta 1, at some
point I will not
be able to get theta
2 because theta 2 will
be arcsine 1.5 sine 1.
And at some point, 1.5 sine
theta 1 will be greater than 1,
then I don't have
a theta 2, which
can satisfy this equation.
So what will happen?
Maybe the whole system
explodes, I don't know.
So we are going to do
a simple experiment
to see what is going to happen.
So before we do this kind
of dangerous experiment,
we are going to turn this
light off and be prepared.
Hope everybody will survive.
So here I have a laser, which is
actually shooting a laser beam
through this tank of water.
So this is water, with
n value roughly 1.33.
And outside of water is air,
so the speed of the light
is roughly equal to c.
So n value is
actually roughly 1.
So that's actually exactly the
situation we are looking for.
And let's turn on this
experiment, careful.
Wow, look at this.
You can see that here there
was no light coming out.
Why is that?
Because of the mathematics--
the mathematics say
that, OK, sorry, guys,
theta 2 doesn't work.
Therefore, there will be
no light really coming out.
You can see my hand, you
can see the light here.
When I put my hand here,
it's not burning my hand.
But that's OK.
All right, and you can see
that nothing really comes out.
And all the energy are
bounced back into the water.
The same thing
also happened here.
You can see that the
light is actually
bouncing back and forth and
moving into the left-hand side
direction until it passed
through here, maybe into there,
because it's actually
still bouncing around
inside this tank.
So the good news is that
no explosion, like what we
have here.
The interesting thing we
find is that all the energy
will be bounced back if you
have large enough incident
angle in this situation.
As you can see from here that
all the light's energy are
bounced back into water.
So that's actually
very, very interesting.
And that means we
can probably make
use of this property to send
light through some large n
material.
So that's actually how
optical fiber works.
So basically you can
actually shoot a light
into the optical fiber.
And the light is going to
be bouncing back and forth
between the boundaries
inside the fiber.
And then you can actually send
those information through light
by this kind of mechanism.
So that's how optical
fiber actually works.
And we have a setup,
which I have a light here,
shooting light into
the optical fiber.
And I have paper
here which tried
to block part of the light.
So from here, you can see the
text which I put on the paper,
because some of the
light is blocked
by this paper, the
text on the paper.
And this light goes
through this optical fiber
and continues and propagates
and got captured by the camera.
So you can see, can
you read out loud
what is actually written there?
Can you see it?
The--
AUDIENCE: Last question on the
YEN-JIE LEE: The exam is--
oh, no, no, no, no,
transmission interrupted.
Oh my god.
All right, so I'm
sorry it didn't work,
but it worked in the
beginning, right?
So you can see that
this is a wonderful way
to send optical signal.
And we actually do that.
We send signal from US to Asia
through all those crazy lines
under the sea.
So that's really cool.
And finally before
we change the topic,
I'm sure that you will enjoy
doing the practice in your PSET
number 8.
We are going to learn that
this is actually highly related
to a beautiful phenomena
we see in daily life--
the rainbow is actually
really related to Snell's law,
and that you are going to
solve this problem in the PSET.
All right, so any
questions so far related
to Snell's law and
refraction index, et cetera?
All right, so if not,
we'll go ahead and talk
about the second example.
The second example
is that instead
introducing more
objects in this array,
we could change the
direction of the oscillation
as a function of time and
see what is going to happen.
For example, the direction
of the electric field,
I can make it rotate or
change as a function of time.
And that's actually called
circularly polarized wave.
And that means we are going to
talk about polarization today.
Before we start
the real lecture,
what we are going
to do is that I
will quote words from Feynman.
"It doesn't matter how
beautiful your theory is,
it doesn't matter
how smart you are,
but if it doesn't agree
with experiment, is wrong."
So that's actually a
very important lesson.
And I have been telling you
that electromagnetic wave is
predicted to be oscillating
in the transverse direction,
as you can see from
that little figure.
So if the directional
of propagation
is to the right-hand side,
so that means electric field
and the magnetic field
can only be oscillating
in a plane which is
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation.
That's actually
what we have learned
from Maxwell's equation.
But all those things
are theory, right?
Do you believe those theory?
I'm not sure.
Maybe light is
actually oscillating
in the longitudinal
direction, right?
If you are a physicist, you
should ask this question.
Maybe you'll find
something which
is inconsistent with the theory,
then you'll feel really happy.
So the question we
are trying to answer
is how do we know the
electromagnetic waves are
transverse waves.
And we are going to work
through a few examples
to convince ourselves,
maybe that's the case,
maybe we have some hint.
Of course, we cannot prove
100% but very likely this is
probably the case.
So let's go ahead and
start the discussion today.
So instead of adding
one more dimension
by arranging materials,
we can actually
discuss how the pointing
direction of the electric field
depends as a function of time.
So in order to do that,
I need to remind you
how to write down electric field
for the electromagnetic wave.
So in a previous lecture,
if I organize myself
so that the
electromagnetic field is
going in the z direction--
the electromagnetic field
is going in the z direction.
All right, if I choose that,
then basically electric field
as a function of
z and time will be
equal to the real part of
some vector psi 0 times
exponential i kz minus omega t.
If I assume that
this electric field,
the electromagnetic field
is propagating to where--
the z direction, right?
So by now, you should
get used to this already.
This is going to the
positive z direction.
Where I intentionally
write psi 0
there is actually a vector which
contains two components-- psi 1
in the x direction and
psi 2 in the y direction.
And you can see from here
that you can immediately
recognize that this
can be returned
as a superposition of two waves.
So one is actually
electromagnetic wave
with electric field
in the x direction.
And the other wave, the
other electromagnetic wave,
is actually oscillating
with electric field in the y
direction and with
amplitude psi 2.
So that is one you can
get immediately because
of the superposition principle.
So it's a superposition of
two electromagnetic waves.
And of course, in
this case, I take
the real part of this vector.
So in general, psi 1 can
be a1 exponential i phi 1.
And in general psi 2 can
be a2 exponential i phi 2.
So in this notation
basically, we write everything
in terms of vector.
And sometimes we write those
things in terms of matrix,
and that sometimes serve a
better purpose for calculation.
So we can also rewrite
this thing in matrix form.
So I have a matrix E which have
two components, E x and E y.
And this is actually equal to
a real part of some Z matrix,
which also contain two
components, times a scalar,
which is exponent
i kz minus omega t.
So as can see, I am
now just setting up
the language we want to
speak so that we communicate.
So in this case, the z matrix
is written as psi 1 and psi 2,
which are the two components.
One is in the x
direction, the other one
is in the y direction.
And we are going to
use this language
and see what we learn from it.
So you can see that we
have been discussing
electromagnetic wave,
which is propagating
toward the positive z direction.
And I have two component
which I can have--
x direction electric field and
y direction electric field.
So let me try to go
through some example
and see what we can
actually learn from this.
So the first example I
would like to talk about
is that if I have two waves, E1.
The first wave is
actually E0 cosine kz
minus omega t in
the x direction.
And then the second wave
is E2 equal to E0 cosine
kz minus omega t,
in the y direction.
Be careful-- the direction
of the electric field
is different for the first
and the second plane wave.
And if you actually notice
from this expression,
these two waves are in phase.
So in-phase means that they
reach maxima at the same time.
So in this case, if I add two
waves with no phase difference,
what is going to happen?
So I am going to have a E
vector, which is E1 plus E2.
And if I plug the locus of
this kind of electric field
in the two-dimensional space,
x and y, so now I am plotting,
so I am fixing my z
position for example at 0.
And I would like to see
how the locus of the E
vary as a function of time.
In this case, since E1 and E2
have the same amplitude, which
is E0, and also they
have no phase difference,
that means they reach
maxima simultaneously.
So that means originally,
for example, in the beginning
the electric field is 0.
And this electric field
projection to the xy plane
will increase
until some maximum.
At the maxima, this will
be E0, the x and y position
will be E0.
Then it goes back to
minus E0, minus E0,
in the x and y
direction position.
And it goes back and forth.
So in this case, this
is actually still not
very different from
what we had discussed
before because the
electric field is still
oscillating up and down.
But the difference
is that it's not
oscillating at the
x-axis or y-axis,
but in the axis which is
actually 45 degree with respect
to the x or y-axis.
And now we can do a
exercise to write it down
in the matrix notation.
Now I have this E matrix will
be equal to the real part of E0,
E0.
And both E0's are real,
exponential i kz minus omega t.
And basically I can conclude
that z will be equal to E0, E0,
and this will be E0, 1, 1.
In this kind of situation,
the electric field
is varying as a
function of time.
The position to xy
plane is a line.
When I happens, we call
it linearly polarized.
So this is actually just a name.
But indeed the locus of the
electric field on the xy plane
is a linear line, so that we
call it linearly polarized.
And of course you can say,
OK, this is just one example.
I can have many, many
examples which you also create
a line when you plot the locus.
So for example, I can
have z equal to E0, 1, 0.
Can somebody tell me what
does that notation mean?
AUDIENCE: That just means
one wave electromagnetic wave
in one direction.
YEN-JIE LEE: That's right.
So that means you only
have electric field
in the x direction.
So this is the x direction,
this is y direction.
And this is also
linearly polarized.
Of course you can have
very similarly E0, 0, 1.
And in this case, you
only have electric field
in the y direction.
Just want to tell
you my language
I'm introducing here
so that we communicate.
And of course, you can have
z equal to E0 cosine theta
sine theta.
What does that mean?
This means that when I plot
the locus on the xy plane,
I'm going to have a
straight line still,
but now the angle between
this line and the x-axis
is going to be theta.
So all those examples, you
can see that in the first case
the oscillation is
in the x direction.
And in the second
case the oscillation
is in the y direction.
And then in the third case it
can be in an arbitrary line--
theta angle away
from the x-axis.
So all those things
are linearly polarized.
So so far, there is
nothing to surprise you.
So that's what we have
been talking about.
And you can say
that, Professor Lee,
you were just not
doing a very good job.
You didn't rotate the axis right
so that all the electric field
is in the x direction.
So in principle for the
discussion of the linearly
polarized wave, you
can do a good job
by rotating your
axis so that you only
have one component
in the x direction.
So I say, OK, yes, I agree,
but this is useful discussion.
All right, so now
maybe you're bored.
They have no phase
difference, right?
So how about we introduce some
phase difference and see what
will happen.
So now if I consider
the second situation--
I have E1 is equal to
E0 cosine kz minus omega
t in the x direction.
Now I consider E2, this would
be E0 sine kz minus omega t
in the y direction.
I hope you can see it.
And then you can see that now
they reach the x component
and y component electric field.
They reach maxima at different
times because of the phase
difference.
How big is the phase difference?
Can somebody actually remind me?
AUDIENCE: Pi over 2.
YEN-JIE LEE: Pi
over 2, very good.
All right, so this
I can write it
down as E0 cosine kz
minus omega t minus pi
over 2, as you
already figured out.
And now I can also again write
it in the language I like,
the matrix format.
Before I achieve that, I can
write it as a real part of E0
in the x direction plus E0
exponential minus i pi over 2,
because this minus
pi over 2 sign,
the factor here for
the y direction.
And all those things are
multiplied by exponential i kz
minus omega t.
Both of them are actually
oscillating at the same omega
angular frequency.
And you can see that now I can
collect this phase difference
back into a complex factor here,
exponential minus i pi over 2.
And exponential minus i pi over
2 is actually just minus i.
So basically you can figure
out that it's just minus i.
So then I can write down my
expression for the E matrix.
This one look like
real part E0, 1,
minus i, exponential
i kz minus omega t.
And in this case, z
vector will be 1 minus i
in the language which
I introduced today.
Everybody is following?
Am I going too fast?
Very good.
Thank you for the feedback.
So now I'm going to
do the same thing
to plot the locus of
the electric field
as a function of
time on the xy plane.
So now you can see that
it's pretty interesting.
Since I have a cosine and sine,
I assume that t is equal to 0,
z is equal to 0,
then I will only
have electric field
in the x direction.
So this is actually
when t is equal to 0.
All right, and if
I increase time,
I fix the z to be equal to 0.
If I increase the
time, this locus
is going to do an
interesting thing.
It's going to be rotating
until it finish one period.
Why is that happening?
Because what I'm plotting is
the locus of the electric field.
And you can see that if
I set z equal to 0, when
z is equal to 0,
this will give you
E0 cosine omega t
in the x direction
and E0 sine omega t
in the y direction.
So E0 cosine omega t,
E0 sine omega t-- wow,
this reminds you about
the previous discussion.
If you have a cosine
and a sine, they
work together in different
directions, that's
going to get you a circle.
So that's why in this
locus you see a circle.
And it's rotating in a
counter-clockwise direction.
And the speed of the rotation
is related to omega t.
And now if I increase
the time, then this point
is going to be going in a
counter-clockwise direction.
And you may be super surprised
because what I have been doing
is to add two linearly
polarized waves together.
The only thing
which I always say,
the magic I have been doing,
is to introduce a phase
difference.
And you can see that instead
of going up and down,
up and down as a
function of time, now
it's actually doing rotation.
So what is going to happen is
that as a function of the time
the direction of
the electric field
is going to rotate as
a function of time.
So we call this situation
circularly polarized.
By the way, because of
the initial two components
I put in, both of them
have amplitude E0.
Therefore, it's
circularly polarized.
I can also try to do
something different.
For example, I can
change the x direction.
So the third situation
is that I can
change the first x direction
amplitude from E0 to E0 over 2.
Then what I'm going to get
is something like this.
The only thing which I
change with respect to 2
is that I changed the
amplitude of the electric field
in the x direction
by a factor of 2.
Can somebody
actually tell me what
is going to happen
in this situation?
What will happen to the locus?
AUDIENCE: Gets squished.
YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah,
it gets squished in,
so in the x direction.
Yeah, that's right, very good.
So what you are going to get
is that instead of a circle
you get something like this.
So this is the x direction
and this is the y direction.
And this will give you a
maxima x equal to E0 over 2.
And of course the original
amplitude in the y direction
didn't change, and that gives
you a maximum value of E0.
And this becomes an
elliptically polarized wave.
So this kind of situation is
called elliptically polarized.
How do we actually
visualize this situation?
So that means, as
in the beginning,
when the electric field is
aligned with the x-axis,
it's pointing in the x-axis.
It has a shorter length.
And when it rotate, rotate as a
function of time to the y-axis,
the amplitude becomes bigger.
And it gets smaller
again, and increase again,
it becomes bigger.
So you can see the
amplitude is actually
changing as a function of time.
When you have this
kind of situation,
they have different amplitudes,
although they have a fixed
phase difference, so pi over 2.
Any questions so far?
OK, so if you noticed
that there's actually
another way to produce
elliptically polarized wave.
What we could do is that
instead of changing the phase
by a factor of pi over 2, we
can change the phase difference.
The phase difference
can be delta
phi, which is the
phase difference,
can be a different value,
arbitrary value, not equal
to pi over 2 or 3 pi over 2.
If the delta phi, which is
the phase difference between x
and the y direction, EM waves--
electric field.
If the phase difference is not
pi over 2 or not 2 pi over 2,
then you can also create an
elliptically polarized wave.
So that starts from
the original figure,
which we actually discussed--
situation number 1.
Situation number 1,
I have delta phi,
the phase difference equal to 0.
When that happened, you have
a linearly polarized wave.
Basically what you
are going to get
is a line in this
two-dimensional space.
If I increase, so now
I slightly delayed.
If I slightly delay the electric
field in the y direction.
So if I slightly delay electric
field it in the y direction
so that delta phi now is greater
than 1, what is going to happen
is that it's going
to look like this.
This means that they will
not reach maxima really
simultaneously.
There will be because
of the phase difference.
And you'll see that
originally when
there were no phase
difference, you
would be oscillating back
and forth in this blue line.
When you increase the
delta phi slightly,
then you are going to get
also a elliptical shape,
but now is tilted with
some degree, which
is 45 degree in this case.
So therefore you can
see that now I can also
create this is also
elliptically polarized wave,
I can also create
elliptically polarized wave
by adding two components, which
they have some slight phase
difference.
So that is actually how I
can create a something which
is called circularly polarized
or elliptically polarized.
Originally before you
come into this class,
it may look really
completely bizarre
that, oh, I can have
electric field going up
and down as a function of time.
But how could I rotate
this thing, right?
Looks really strange.
How can I see this from
the Maxwell's equation?
But now you get the idea.
Basically, that's because I
can now overlap two components.
Both components individually
are linearly polarized.
But if I introduce
a phase difference,
then the superposition
of these two components
become something
which is actually
rotating as a function of time.
And that's pretty interesting.
So let's visualize what
we have learned so far.
The first one is
linearly polarized.
Actually, it doesn't
surprise you--
that's the example
which we have been
using in the previous lectures.
And this is the situation of
circularly polarized wave.
So let's focus on the
figure at z equal to 0.
So you can see that in
this case the direction
of the electric
field is actually
rotating as a function of time.
And of course as we
discussed, I can actually
add two electric fields
with different amplitudes
or introduce slightly
different phase,
then you will see that not only
that the direction is changing,
but also the
amplitude is changing.
And in this case we call it
elliptically polarized wave.
Any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the magnitude
always is constant with time
now?
YEN-JIE LEE: Yes,
so the magnitude,
or say the intensity, is
proportional to E squared,
right?
So it's actually a constant.
So now let me add
more excitement here.
So now suppose I have a
perfect conductor, all right.
So what I am going
to do is that I'm
going to introduce some
more excitement by shooting
this linearly polarized
wave through some material.
If I have a perfect conductor
where all those strips,
I have only strips of perfect
conductor instead of a plate--
we were talking
about plate before.
And the lesson we
learned is that the plate
is going to refract the
electromagnetic wave
because that electrons
on the plate is so busy,
it's trying to make sure
that the electric field
in the surface of the
plate is equal to 0
because that all those electrons
are really moving around.
So that's making sure the
electric field is canceled.
And therefore, it's
going to refract
the electromagnetic wave.
So how about I
restrict the direction
of the movement of the electron
so that it can only move
in the horizontal direction?
What is going to happen
is that in this case,
the electric field is actually
oscillating up and down.
And the electrons see this
field and they will say,
no, no, no, this
is not why we work.
This is not we are
going to vote for.
And I'm going to rearrange
ourselves to compensate that,
all right.
And they were
asking, can I move.
Oh yes, I can move in
the horizontal direction.
So they jump up and down,
then they can actually
cancel this electric field.
Therefore, what
is going to happen
when we have this
perfect conductor is
that the electromagnetic field
is going to be bounced back
like what we had before when
we talked about a metal plate,
all right.
So that's actually pretty nice.
Now suppose I have
another perfect conductor.
If I have another
perfect conductor,
this time the perfect
conductor is arranged such
that all those charges can
only move inside or outside
of the board instead
of going up and down.
Now I have the incident wave,
which is actually polarized
in the horizontal direction.
So you can see that
this time the electrons
are really nervous about this.
And oh no, I have
to do something,
but they cannot
move up and down.
Therefore, what
is going to happen
is that there will be no
cancellation of electric field
at this boundary.
And this polarized
wave can pass through
this so-called polarizer
or perfect conductor
without getting stopped
or get refracted.
And as you can see that
in these two examples,
I have so called the easy axis.
So you can see that the
easy axis, as the name
should tell you, so easy axis
is the axis which is easy.
All right, so what
does that mean?
That means if I have
electric field aligned
with the easy axis,
it will pass through.
And the easy axis is
perpendicular to the direction
of all those streets I have
in the perfect conductor.
Let's look at the first example.
It tells you that the
electric field is not
aligned with the easy axis.
That means it's
not easy, so it got
refracted-- oh, life is hard.
And the second electric
field is smarter.
It got aligned
with the easy axis.
So life is easy,
it passed through.
That's how I remember
this so-called easy axis.
Any questions?
So we have been talking
about all those crazy names
of polarized light.
And I hope that you also have
learned about unpolarized light
before.
Most of the lights
are unpolarized.
For example, light emitted
from those light bulbs
are not polarized because
every emission of a photon
can be aligned in
different direction.
Therefore, as I
was talking about,
there are an infinite number
of photons hitting my face
and bouncing back to your eye.
All those things are not
aligned to the same direction
as what we have been
discussing before.
In the case of linearly
polarized wave,
all the electric fields are
pointing to the same direction.
And apparently those lights
hitting my face is not aligned
and it's actually pointing
to random directions.
So that brings me to the
fifth situation, which
I would like to talk about.
The fifth situation is that I
could have unpolarized light.
So what do I mean by
unpolarized light?
That means electromagnetic
waves which
were produced independently
by a large number
of uncorrelated source.
You may ask, OK,
wait, wait, wait--
unpolarized means that we have
a lot of different light source
pointing to different angles.
Shouldn't it just
look like this?
So you have pointing this
direction, all the directions,
all the possible
directions, pointing
to all different possible
directions, like this.
Shouldn't that diagram
actually tell you
something about
unpolarized light?
Life is hard.
If everything is
aligned and also
arriving at the same time like
this, what is going to happen?
They cancel, right?
Because all those
things are vectors.
If they reach maxima
at the same time,
this means that they
are emitting always
at the same time, but
in random direction.
And emitting at the
same wavelength,
then they are going
to cancel each other.
So apparently that's not what
I mean by unpolarized light.
What I mean is that
they can be pointing
to different directions,
but that emission
time and the wavelength of all
those emitted electromagnetic
waves can be slightly
different, otherwise they
will just cancel each
other completely.
Any questions about
what I just said?
So very good.
So now what I am going to do
is to show you some examples
related to polarizer.
Before that, I will take a
five minute break before we
come back to the demonstration.
So we will come back at 36.
OK, so welcome back.
So we would continue the
discussion of the polarization
and the polarized wave
and the polarizers.
So before that, I already
introduced the polarizer
by the perfect conductor
arranged in the x direction
or y direction, many
of them are strips,
aligned in the x direction
and the y direction.
And usually we use
a simple diagram
like this, a circle
and an arrow,
to indicate the easy
axis to tell you
about the property
of the polarizer.
So in this case,
if I have a circle
and I have an arrow, which is
pointing toward the x-axis,
in this case my
coordinate system is here,
horizontal is x,
vertical is y, that
means my easy axis is
in the x direction.
And I can actually
write down what
would be the matrix presentation
of p0, which would present
the effect of this polarizer.
The p0 will be a matrix
in this form, 1, 0, 0, 0.
If I have this P0
acting on the z,
for example, I can have the
p0 acting on the z, then
basically what would happen
after the light passed
through this polarizer will
become z multiplied by p0.
So basically all
this p0 matrix does
is to extract the position
of the field in the x-axis.
But I'm just writing it
down in the matrix format.
And on the other
hand, for example, I
can have this easy axis,
which is 90 degrees, which
affects the x-axis, which
is in the y direction,
then I write this down in
the form of p pi over 2.
This pi over 2 is the
angle between the easy axis
and the x direction.
And in this case, you
are going to get 0, 0, 0,
1 because all this
matrix set notation
does is to extract the
component which is actually
in the y direction.
And you can of course multiply--
when you have an incident
electromagnetic wave
which you can extract the
polarization z matrix, you just
multiply p pi over 2 and z.
Basically you can actually
get the resulting polarization
of the electromagnetic
field after passing
through this polarizer.
What is going to happen is
that only the y component
will survive.
In the case of easy axis
aligned in the x direction,
only the x component
will survive.
So now let me go through
a short example here.
So suppose initially I have
an electromagnetic field
polarized, it's linearly
polarized in the y direction.
And I have that
electromagnetic field
passing through a polarizer,
which is actually theta
degree away from the y-axis.
So what is going to happen is
that all the components which
is parallel to the axis survive.
All the projected components
in the axis perpendicular
to the easy axis didn't make it
because the electrons are going
to be oscillating up
and down like crazy
to compensate and then
refract that component.
So what is going to happen
is that after passing
through the easy axis, the
direction of the polarization
will be altered such
that it's actually
in line with the easy
axis of the polarizer.
So you can see
that, after passing
through this polarizer, the
direction of the polarization,
this is still
linearly polarized,
the direction is
changed by theta degree.
And also the
amplitude also changed
because only the component
parallel to the easy axis
survived.
Therefore, the magnitude
of the E vector
becomes E0 cosine
of cosine theta.
And therefore, the amplitude
of the light got reduced.
It becomes I0
cosine theta squared
because the intensity
of the light
is proportional to E squared.
So after all this, this
is time to take a look
at some demonstration here.
So here I have a setup.
I have emission of linearly
polarized microwave
from the left-hand side,
which is the source.
And I have a receiver which
is connected to this scope.
You can see the
result on the scope.
You can see that
indeed they are energy
passing from this source.
And it got accepted and
then recorded by the scope.
Now I have all of those--
OK, all are not so
perfect, but those
are metals which have
many, many strips
or many, many little rods here.
And my initial
linearly polarized wave
is actually pointing in
the vertical direction.
So if I have my polarizer
arranged in this direction,
can you predict what will happen
to the readout on the scope?
Will I see signal or not?
How many of you think
we will see signal
if I arrange that the
electromagnetic wave is
polarized in the up
and down direction?
OK, one, two, three--
only four people think so.
How many of you think nothing
will be observed by the scope?
Most of you actually think so.
So let's really do
this experiment.
Look at what is happening.
Can you see it?
Do I see a signal?
No.
All the signals are
canceled, right?
Why?
Because all the hard work of all
those electrons in the metal,
they are like crazy, oh my
god, this is a disaster.
I am going to oscillate up and
down-- cancel, cancel, cancel.
Then it got cancelled.
On the other hand, I can
save all those electrons.
So now I'm going to rotate
this thing by 90 degrees
and see what is going to happen.
Can you see it?
Nothing happened, right?
Because those electrons--
oh my god, crisis coming,
but now there's nothing I can
do because I cannot move up
and down.
Therefore, there will
be no refraction.
So they have just
to accept the fact
that this electromagnetic
field went through.
All right, and
that actually does
something really interesting.
Look at this-- so
now I can actually
make electromagnetic field
completely destroyed,
because originally the
electromagnetic field is
linearly polarized, up and
down in this direction.
So if I have a plate
which is 45 degrees
and I put in another one here--
it doesn't really
work very well.
The signal probably
is too small.
How about we do this
demo in a different way.
So right now here I
have my computer here.
Can you see my computer?
You can see the screen, right?
The screen essentially
is made of LED.
Those LED screens
emit polarized light.
And those are the
polarizer, which
is the equivalent
version of those metals
but arranged in a
really fine grain--
so you cannot really
see all those strips.
And they look
pretty transparent.
But the idea is pretty similar.
And the polarizing axis is
in the horizontal direction.
The easy axis is in
horizontal direction.
So let me put this here.
Can you still see the screen?
You cannot, right.
But if I rotate this by 90
degrees, you can see it.
That is because all
those light emitted
from the screen it
linearly polarized
up and down direction.
So now if I have another
identical polarizer which I
insert between these two, so
now you cannot see anything
because all the light
is pointing up and down,
or the electric field
is pointing up and down.
And now if I insert another
one, which is 45 degrees,
can you see something?
You can see it-- why?
That is because if I insert this
additional polarizer, like what
I was discussing,
it's going to take
the position to the
direction of the easy axis.
And if I have another one,
which is the easy axis pointing
toward the x direction, then
again since this vector is
tilted already by
some theta degree,
then you can see some
residual component
which can pass through
the second polarizer.
On the other hand, if I remove
this polarizer in between,
then what is going to happen
is that all the components
is pointing to the y direction.
Then you cannot see any
component which pass through
this polarizer.
So that's actually
pretty interesting.
And I can rotate
this, and you can see
that the magnitude is changing.
Only when I have 45 degrees,
I see a maximum intensity.
Any questions?
Very good.
So now what I'm going to
do is to discuss with you
an interesting question,
which was posted by Einstein.
Einstein said that, as I
said, "God doesn't play dice
with the world."
So that's actually
what he believed.
So we can do an interesting
experiment, which
I have single photon source.
So what do I mean by
single photon source?
I can emit one
photon at a time--
just one, and then the second
one, and the third one--
and have then pass through
some imaginary polarizer.
So let's suppose
I have unpolarized
light with intensity at 0.
So basically, after it
passed through this polarizer
with a axis pointing
to the x direction,
in this case the x
direction is pointing
to this direction, what
you are going to get
is that you are going
to filter from all
those unpolarized
direction, you are
going to filter only the light
which is actually parallel
to the easy axis.
So therefore, after the
unpolarized light source
passes through
this polarizer, you
are going to have all
the electric field
pointing to the x direction.
Now everybody can accept.
And of course if I have
a second one, which
is in the y direction,
since there will
be no component pointing
to the y direction,
you get zero electric field.
That's very nice.
So Einstein was
really happy that, oh,
that means unpolarized
light maybe is just 50%
of the polarized light
in the x direction
and 50% of the polarized
light in the y direction.
Because each time I emit one
photon, the first half of them
got stopped by the x
direction easy axis polarizer.
And then the second
half got stopped
by the second polarizer.
So that probably makes sense.
But how about-- as we did
in the demonstration--
how about we rotate the second
polarizer by 45 degrees?
What will be the intensity?
But now, hey, you cannot split
a single photon because a photon
is a photon.
How can I split, right?
Because if I describe
my unpolarized light
as 50% linearly polarized in
x, the other half is linearly
polarized in y,
then I am in trouble
because I don't know
how to calculate
what is this intensity.
So basically maybe all of them
pass through or all of them
doesn't pass through.
Then we can do this experiment.
And this is the result--
what you are going to
get is that the intensity
is going to be I0 over 4.
That is actually
not 0 or I over 2.
So that means really
the nature of plate
dies because a single photon is
equivalent to something which
can be described by a wave.
So that gives us some
possible connection
to quantum mechanics,
because that
means a single photon is not
like a single object, which
is actually passing through
all those polarizers.
But they actually
act also like waves.
So that is something which we'll
follow up with later lectures.
When we talk about
interference, et cetera,
we are going to also
discuss related issues
about the connection
to quantum mechanics.
So today, we
actually have learned
about polarization, linearly
polarized, circularly
polarized, and
elliptically polarized
electromagnetic waves, and
also unpolarized light source.
And we have learned
about how to produce
polarized electromagnetic
wave with polarizer.
Basically have the
unpolarized light
source pass through a polarizer,
you'll have a polarized light.
We didn't cover
quarter wave plate yet.
We are going to
cover that next time.
And also, next time we will
talk about how we actually can
generate electromagnetic field.
We have been talking about
electromagnetic field
for a long time, but
how are they actually
generated is an issue which
we have actually touched.
And that is actually going
to happen after the midterm
next week.
Thank you very much.
And if you have any
questions, please let me know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]